welcome to the David Pakman show I'm
fairing cousins from Ring of Fire
sitting in for David Pakman today
obviously a lot to talk about yesterday
was a pretty big news day and the
biggest news we got out of yesterday is
the fact that Paul Manafort is gonna
spend a little bit more time in prison
than he had originally thought Paul
Manafort returned in front of a judge
yesterday to get the rest of his
sentence this one pretty decent not
great you know obviously if he were a
different person
perhaps somebody not well politically
connected perhaps somebody with no money
he would be spending a few decades in
prison instead he got an additional
forty three months added to his sentence
pretty weak but there is a silver lining
to all of this because less than one
hour after the judge yesterday added an
additional forty three months on demand
afford sentence for the additional
crimes that he had committed new york
prosecutors announced hey wait we also
have some charges we would like to file
against mr. manna for these charges
include mortgage fraud falsifying
business records to illegally obtain
millions of dollars as part of a
years-long mortgage fraud scheme for
which he could face 8 to 25 years in
prison
what's significant about these charges
other than the fact that hey he may go
to prison for even longer is the fact
that these are state charges and this is
why those are so important because manna
fort might be able to get a presidential
pardon for the previous sentences that
he's received in convictions but he
can't be pardoned for these these are
state crimes not federal crimes so there
is no pardon to be dangled from the
Trump administration mr. Manafort is
likely going to be spending a very very
long time in prison the other thing
about this though is that obviously man
afford right now
gonna get credit for I think nine months
of time served he's going to start
serving his sentence and then a few
weeks down the road because this
investigation is ongoing he is going to
have to go to New York be arraigned and
then face the charges there likely to be
another lengthy trial followed by a
sentencing hearing the chances of
Manafort making it out of prison really
at this point for the rest of his life
getting slimmer by the day and these
charges filed in New York less than an
hour after this other sentence was
handed down this was no coincidence they
were waiting they wanted to see what was
going to happen with this other
sentencing and they didn't want to
interrupt it they didn't want to
supersede it they didn't want that judge
to change their sentence ruling based on
these new accusations now they let the
process play out and then as soon as it
had finished they said by the way don't
forget to send him our way because we
may need to add a few more years on to
that sentence as well a lot of people
wondering what does this mean for Donald
Trump well the unfortunate answer is
nothing these charges really have
nothing to do with Donald Trump just
Paul Manafort being a criminal for many
many many many years and it finally
caught up to him he wasn't able to
conceal the lies to conceal the fraud to
conceal the conspiracies any more so
does this affect Donald Trump not
necessarily so you know whatever that
means Manta Ford's going away this
doesn't affect Trump in fact lawyers in
court actually tried to bring up the
collusion issue to which the judge
yesterday said no stop it irrelevant
doesn't matter for what we're doing here
now Trump actually took those statements
to mean that the judge said that hey I
didn't commit any collusion at all this
whole thing's a witch hunt and this
judge just proved it not at all what
happened not even close the judge just
said we're not here to talk about
collusion
I'm talking about all of these financial
crimes and that's what we're gonna focus
on because I'm not the judge for the
collusion issue Trump didn't take it
that way